thank you very much for having me here I
greatly appreciate it I greatly
appreciate the effort it took to get up
aurilla maybe never go to bed to be here
this morning my name is Dave core smart
I am from NASA Ames and I'm going to
talk about a piece of NASA's activities
I want to do due diligence and note that
NASA stands for National Aeronautics and
Space Administration Aeronautics the
little a I will not talk about it is
important we do really cool stuff there
and space I'm going to talk about both
robotic and manned space but space the
up-and-out not the down and in we also
do a lot of space or science not going
to talk too much about that today so I'm
just going to give you a little bit of a
venue of what's going on in how we're
using kind of gigapixel imagery in
general to do our exploration first just
a little synopsis NASA Ames well that
sounds interesting why do I say NASA
Ames why not just say NASA NASA actually
has 10 centers some people don't know
that so I'm giving you a little quickie
here located around the country the one
that I'm most fond of is NASA Ames were
basically they like to say in the heart
of Silicon Valley it means at the bottom
of the San Francisco Bay okay Stanford's
across the way from us Google's right
next door to us UC Berkeley's across the
bay we have all sorts of cool stuff here
and and you know right on our site here
right about there is a CMU Silicon
Valley right so they're actually on our
facility so when we talk about actually
being jointly connected that's what
we're talking about so that's the
research that I'm talking about and our
particular one of our key areas of
interest is in computer science and
information technology ergo it makes
sense to do stuff with CMU as an example
so let me start with Mars why am I
starting with Mars well in some sense it
all started here for ela and Randy and
Anne and Matt Dean's and a number of
other people because we were supporting
a rather popular little Mars rover set
Spirit and Opportunity which landed on
Mars jus
january fourth 2004 and ames was a
tasked that's part of our the NASA team
to work on the imagery that was coming
down from these pan camps which are this
is called the mast and the boom and the
panorama cameras and you know it's a
kind of a clever idea it's a little
fancy high-res a digital camera that's
on a robot it and it moves ever so
slowly to take a picture perhaps you've
heard about it and so we were taking and
dealing with all that data and we
created not me but we meaning really
Randy and team under ela and I'd like to
point out that eel is on sabbatical from
aims to CMU just just to make sure we
understand each other so we we developed
this the mirimage browser as one of our
tool sets and we were dealing with the
data and playing with it and soon into
it we started developing some particular
software that allowed us to very rapidly
stitch together some of the images a
little less rigorously you might say
than then JPL's rather arduous task of
perfectly aligning every pixel but we
wanted to quickly kind of look at the
data and assess it and drill into it and
see what was going on and so you know
you can see here this is actually at the
landing of spirit the the pods kind of
open do you know the the star seeds
coming out and we're getting the
panorama know it looks kind of
interesting we see some stuff here and
the software if you notice we're going
to zoom in on this point here you know
the software allowed us to kind of zoom
in amongst these tiled images and and
sure enough we're looking for our rock
outcrop and that one looks really good
so we're going to zoom in again and and
that looks like a really nice rock
outcrop and we zoom in it again and lo
and behold you know those those doggone
geologists have been looking for bedrock
and there it is we didn't even roll out
and we got it and we got it really quick
and we got to be able to tell the
team go look with your really high res
go there go there and do your scratch
and stuff because that's the most
important thing now what came from this
is Randy and Larry Edwards and Matt
deans and and right and all working at
NASA Ames all working in ILA's group
they develop this stuff they were
playing around with it and thought well
this is kind of cool we should really do
more things with panoramix because
panoramas are really kind of neat and
what incorrect me when I'm wrong here
ela you know we really like this stuff
but let's start seeing if we can do this
with maybe the then up-and-coming
digital cameras you know you remember
these that was when they were two
megapixel and they cost a couple hundred
dollars or you know they really weren't
the type of SLRs we have today and so we
developed a first cut at this software
and Randy was careful to point out that
JPL produced the actual official
products and you know but we produce the
really cool ones so they got together
and talked about is there something we
can do low costs that it can now us to
make this technology available and they
came up with an idea of a thing called
global connection which is the agreement
we've got in between CMU and if you go
back and you look at some of the early
prototypes I think this is mounted on
the outside of somebody's house yeah and
you know it started just in August so
several months after the the Mars rover
landing gathering pictures and it
gathered stuff like this right you know
and that's a nice backyard and so you
know that's from whence this some of
this comes just to give you a little
context from our perspective and now the
global connection activity which is you
know a partnership of CMU Google
National Geographic NASA is going on
gigapan org you know providing these
very inexpensive within the NASA context
virtually free robotic systems
that allow really participatory
exploration so going back to NASA again
what is change for NASA since Apollo era
right everybody knows the Apollo era you
know boots and suits on the moon well
we've got a lot more horrible assets
we've got a lot more computational
technology allows us to simulations
we've been to actual other planetary
surfaces beyond just the moon and we
have very advanced robotics capabilities
now well gee that's okay is that is that
different does that change things well
yeah it actually it does so if we look
at some NASA exploration targets and I'm
going to take you through a little bit
of the inner solar system again I said
I'm constraining things and for those of
you that don't know this is not to scale
and this does represent our solar system
so you know here's here's us here's the
moon we're going to talk about Mars
we're going to talk about near-earth
objects and we're going to talk about
the asteroid belt a little bit but those
are areas that we're looking believe it
or not at both robotic obviously and
manned exploration you know those are
our targets we're not going to go out to
the main asteroid belt any time real
soon but we'll talk about it so going
back to Mars a little bit what's our
next step as I was talking to people at
lunch you know it was maybe not a common
understanding of our plan because NASA
barely has a common understanding of our
plan because this is actually pretty
recent we just cut a deal where NASA and
the European Space Agency have agreed to
a joint Mars exploration investment
program which is really good because
Europeans do some some wonderful stuff
and so we're combining investments and
combining vehicles and systems and we've
got some wonderful things in the
out-years I'm not going to talk too much
about that but I am going to talk about
this one which is called the Mars
Science Laboratory so we have the MER
Rovers which is many
you know and I just stated landed in
2004 you know it's like Gilligan's
Island you know they were there for a
three-hour to wear these were there for
a three-month tour and they never left
right so they're still there they're
still operating one of them's dug a hole
for itself and it just kind of sitting
around the other ones still moving and
you know that's that's one of our best
investments ever write this this this
Mars Exploration Rover so we're
following it up with the Mars Science
Rover who is not much to live up to but
it's the bigger badder brother of the
Mars rover so we're you know you can
think of this as a golf cart this is
more like the Humvee right that's that's
what they're shooting for and you know
it has all the right words right its
nuclear powered and you know really big
and beefy one of the key things here is
again we're going to have one of these
masks and robotic cameras and lo and
behold you know it's called am a scam
and and we're going to use it to take
big panoramas we're going to use it to
take big three deep aneurysms and we're
going to use it to take something that
we haven't done before which is not
often noticed we don't take video has
anybody noticed that NASA does not take
video we do it in low Earth orbit don't
get me wrong but we've never taken video
on another planet why is that well
because video tends to be much much
lower resolution that the technology
really wasn't there you know you could
bring back a canister a film but you
know if you wanted to take a
high-definition video in the past it had
to be you know photographic plates it
was not something you do and you just
couldn't pull the emmitt the data off
the pixel off the the ccd quick enough
right now you can that's common
technology you've got these HD cameras
that you can buy so NASA is basically
flying one of these I think it's five
frames per second at a high res and 15
frames per second we think at a lower
res so we're actually going to have the
ability to actually capture dynamic
information on the surface of another
planet I think that's tremendously
exciting at high res right now we take
snapshots as quickly as we can and we
can't kompas them together and and run
them and hope nobody notices but it's
not video okay so going from Mars where
we're going to have some really cool
camera imagery how else is now so using
images to explore well I want to give
you a little bit of a step through here
just so that we are all on the same page
when I'm talking about where else we're
talking about going one of the places is
an asteroid now to be specific i'm
talking about what's called a near-earth
asteroid and what i mean by that is its
orbit around the sun is in the vicinity
of the orbit of the earth and they align
every now and then so that it's
relatively close 10 20 million miles
okay about 20 to 40 times the distance
between the Earth in the moon okay so
that's that's close and in our land but
when we're talking about the scale of
the object right here's the limb of Mars
here's a main belt asteroid Ceres which
is really kind of a micro planet here's
Vesta we're actually sending a mission
to those it's now called dawn that'll
get up get there in the in the next year
and we'll get some much better than
these blurry images there's a small rock
here called arrows and a mission called
near went to that that it was a NASA
mission and it looks like this when we
got a close and that's kind of like the
best imagery we have of it right now to
be quite candid and then the Japanese
are really fabulous 12 a small rock and
these are just scale I didn't just lose
the image that little thing down there
is eat ikawa which is another near-earth
asteroid that the Japanese went to and
they're very proudly showing their data
and it looks like
this kind of a weird broken peanut now
just for scale this is the biggest thing
we've ever built in space and this
little thing is you know the Orion
spacecraft which kind of looks like a
fat Apollo spacecraft right so if we're
talking about sending a manned mission
to an asteroid this is a baby and this
is what it would look like okay now the
Japanese the mission was called hayabusa
spacecraft was called Hayabusa that went
there they collected some some really
fabulous data and again remember NASA
and most of the other spacefaring
nations when we talk about exploring a
space we explore in pictures we have no
choice but to explore in pictures
because how else are we going to do it
you know it's it's some visible spectra
or some spectrum that we then map back
to a visible spectra so that we can
understand it were visible creatures so
if you look at the neck in between here
sorry the neck part and between the two
lobes of this kind of weird
potato-shaped asteroid they were looking
for a good place to actually do a sample
where basically the spacecraft was going
to fly bump into the surface and then
hopefully some particulates would come
up they would close a latch and they fly
it back and they have indeed limped back
to earth did they did a fabulous job
getting home but we don't know if
there's any any samples yet but they
were targeting this and they were
looking at all these various outcrops
and you can see how flaky it is right
the lighting is very weird it's a rubble
pile basically is what it looks like so
what they got is they got limited
imagery as they were going in you know
at 80 meters you could see this here's
the kind of meter scale bar and this is
you know the PowerPoint experts gigapan
the 68 meters and then at 63 meters and
then a touchdown and so this is you know
kind of pebble sized
small almond size gravel that's that's
there now one of the things that they're
doing is they're actually attempting to
put this into full mosaics they haven't
got there yet we're trying to negotiate
to get access to some of the data to
allow that to occur but you can see and
they're also going back I should be
careful to say they're going back with a
mark two of the Hayabusa to a different
asteroid and this time they're taking
basically you know megapixel class
imagery systems with them particularly
to basically do a full mapping of the of
this of the actual asteroid so that's
the type of exploration we're doing on
the asteroid and the idea is you know
eventually you'd send a human mission to
one of these things to do aura or a much
more robust robotic mission to do a
significant sample return of up to
kilograms of things so when we talk
about mapping a planetary body that was
a planetary body and some of the other
things we do in particular at NASA Ames
is is we're looking at how to create
these planetary maps using kind of
derivatives if you would have it of the
same software and techniques that were
that you use for Giga pants how do you
create these high quality digital maps
how do you enable quick easy access some
of that's already been you know defined
by the GigaPan org structure how you
provide very rapid updates we get lots
of data and we want to create these 3d
terrain reconstructions from these
images and we want to provide it in kind
of open data sets that everyone gets
access to where the government believe
it or not we're here to help and this
but in truth from the NASA perspective
you know come on what harm can we do
we're here to basically provide the
forefront of exploration into areas that
we otherwise can't get access to that's
what we do we might as well make the
data available for everybody because you
paid for it so one of the key problems
or challenges for us is that more and
more
and more data is coming back that's a
good thing but it's also a challenge
right when we talked about going to Mars
with some of the first orders this is
Mars Global Surveyor you know we got a
little bit a data and then we sent on
another one Mars Odyssey and then we
sent the MER Rovers and they're
gathering a lot but they're having a lot
more than we thought because really
they've been there so much longer we
sent out what's called the Mars
Reconnaissance Orbiter which was a class
of orbital satellite that you would have
for doing imagery on the earth so it's
the same class of imagery system that
you use for doing remote sensing on the
earth we send it to Mars and they've
given us a big block of data the Apollo
imagery you may remember was not digital
back in the analog age but they took
tremendous photographic historical
records that were now actually
digitizing and using that information
and then you know Celine and Chung e1
and Jean Draya other countries Japanese
China and India and then our own LRO
which is a lunar reconnaissance orbiter
which is there now and has done a full
map at very high resolution of the moon
and we're actually compositing all that
data together i wish i could show you
that i can't show you that right now
because it's unreleased bull but we're
playing with it which is nice so this
gives you an idea of kind of the
magnitude in a different matter of the
firehose we're dealing with right
cartography tends to has traditionally
been a you know mapmaking has been a
human activity right because it's how
things relate to each other it's been
very manual you know we work with a USGS
the the kind of the greatest map makers
in the world they hold the NASA well
they hold the US government's imprint
ear for having the maps of the universe
right so you want to know where
something is on the earth you go to the
USGS and they'll tell you where it is
and it's here related to this related to
some central point if you want to know
the map of the moon guess what the US
geological survey service still even
though it says geological they hold for
other planetary bodies they're the same
one for the moon it's likely they will
expand that domain to other planetary
bodies but right now for the moon there
it too so as we gather the Apollo metric
data they created a lunar body
representation on Mars we're collecting
data lots and lots of data on the lunar
update that's now going into that system
even tremendously more data and we're
scanning you know years of high-res
digital film from the past Apollo era
experiences that we've got you know and
the way we do that is it's a it's a
transact gigapan that's what it is it's
the same thing you're just moving taking
a picture you knowing where you are
finding the overlaps and again the
pictures not videos and then building
building the the appropriate panorama
and with parallax you're allowed to get
out the depth and that gives you
basically the geography right so that's
a problem though because that's a that's
a technical challenge and when NASA Ames
and CMU and others are working on open
source packages and common languages
that we're making available to other
universities and to academics and
Industry to go off and do great things
with that we're using to basically pull
out the 3d contours the 3d surface maps
of these other planets of these other
places and make them representable and
actually put them on sites like yoga
pants so that people can consume and use
them again the acronyms the national
acronym and Space Agency I said we have
lots of them just trust me that's a big
that's one camera that's another camera
and that's another camera and you know
we're able with the different cameras
and the different information sets but
with the same software package need very
general
to pull out these nice surface
topographies and we're doing that for
Mars and then we're basically
integrating these various topographies
to give you the best of the breed right
that's that's what you're really trying
to get and so there was a really nice
talk about how you align GigaPan images
well just imagine right you know it's
this is the the same same idea on a big
scale how do you do that that's a that's
a nice nice challenge this gives you an
idea of a very nice Mars terrain where
you get some very good service
definition we're down to five meters per
pixel so it's at a pretty high
resolution and that's the type of
information we want to have so that when
people go to Mars either virtually or
physically they will be able to explore
and really understand the context of
what's going on you know the speaker
from google yesterday said write a
picture is worth a thousand words right
I get Giga pans like a novel right
there's just lots and lots and lots of
things you can go through time and time
again so the same way we did it for Mars
we're doing it in a bit of an inverted
scale for the moon for the first half
instead of taking a picture of the moon
we're taking a picture of a picture
right we're scanning the film assets
from the the transects that the Apollo
spacecraft did over the surface of the
Moon with their very high quality
photographic then you know chemical
photographic systems and then pulling
out these image maps and creating these
surface topographies and sharing that
and then we're basically with USGS we're
mapping them back on to the actual
archival you know pristine idealized
lunar map and we've got a thing called
the Lunar mapping and balling project
that's doing that and you know just to
give you an idea you know when they went
to the moon they had this very nice
camera here this Apollo mapping camera
and you can go to this site where
there's
archive of the digitized version of a
lot of the the images and they're being
restored and and and being properly
correlated and then we're using that raw
material and putting it all together so
like I said we're basically taking what
were separate snapshots and doing a big
transect in creating a big gig of an and
that allows us a big 3d gigapan and that
allows us then to overlay these things
so that you know you've got the kind of
the traditional moon imagery that you've
pulled together wrapped around the globe
and now we've got a very high resolution
swath of what's going on and and you
know we've geotagged it quote unquote
with all the appropriate craters and all
the cool stuff that's going on and we're
down to you know nice ten meters per
pixel only 80 images but what's coming
soon for Mars is we've got that really
fine high-end cult high rise and it's
you can guess it's high resolution very
nice high resolution system that's going
around Mars and instead of just getting
you know a small swath from the
photographic plates of Apollo and
putting it on the moon we're going to
get some big huge swathes from this very
high resolution camera system that's
going around Mars now and stitch it all
together each of the tiles are it's 256
x 256 there's a lot of them there's way
lot of well there's a lot of root tiles
but there's just 230 million full tiles
we're talking about almost six terabytes
of data that's going to be a gigapan
right
right that's that's what we call what do
you call yesterday the the ped a pan the
exa pan you know you start start losing
things but that's the idea and that's
going to give you a full virtual world
and in some sense to truly explore well
before we get there in person so how do
we make this available for everybody how
do we make this something that that
people can get access to well we want
people I mean that's our goal that's our
week it's written in law if you go back
and you look at the Space Act that was
signed in 1958 for NASA it's written in
law we are to serve the public by making
access to space and others assets and
all its products available to the to the
to the public and so guess what this
little thing called the world wide web
came along and we it's we're still not
that great at it thank God other people
are and so we're trying to get very low
barrier to entry and we're working with
small groups like Google Earth and and
microsoft worldwide telescope and
they're enabling us really to get out
the material the information the data
that we need to gigapan org and allowing
what is now was an original euphemism
for something that was almost derogatory
Oh citizen science has now become the
true massively parallel activity oh my
god citizens islands you know it's free
post it on the web and they'll find all
the hard stuff and we'll just pick out
you know the wheat from the chaff it'll
be great there's a lot of chaff but who
cares look at the wheat right and how
much did it cost not much this I believe
is one of the most significant and
powerful see changes in the way that
NASA will explore because frankly if you
go back if you go there you go there
just this one if you go back how long is
it going to take you know the handful of
paid government researchers to go
through this data far far far too long
right we don't have the manpower we
don't have the skill
they're going to lose the desire and
they're going to get old and die so
citizen science citizen science is
really the way to make this happen right
we there were some good examples
yesterday where they posted things on
the web and you know days later millions
of hits have come through and they found
these nuggets these gems these pieces
and that's a real model that we want to
leverage and make use of so you know
like i said if you go to you know your
google earth browser and you go up you
can select Google Mars you can select
Google moon and you can and if you go to
the microsoft worldwide telescope site
you can select Mars as well and you can
get access to any number of good NASA
data sets and tours so that will take
you through with sometimes written
sometimes audio tours describing how the
data interrelates what you should be
looking for where there is value and
telling you more information than you
probably want to know but you have the
pause button so it works and all of this
is available through open standards so
all of this data then is usable by
anybody by any corporation by any
country for that matter by any academic
institution to learn to understand and
to explore so as I said you know we
partnered excuse me so we partnered with
Google and in 2009 it's just about a
year almost two years ago we released
Mars 3d in Google and we've got all this
wonderful stuff and it's got it had the
best data of the day and we've got a
pipeline now into that system where
we're providing the latest and greatest
as it becomes releasable so it is
available now people are saying oh
you're favoring Google now or not will
partner with anybody who wants to sign a
space act agreement with us even CMU and
you know allow them access to the data
you know there's some some can
straints that we want to be able to
understand how we get it to them and
then they can't go off and sell it again
but they're not selling it again and we
didn't have to develop the system we
don't have to support the servers you
know it's a great partnership you know
we get bill nye the science guy to give
tours I mean an IRA fleet out from NPR I
mean how what else could you want we're
also did that for Google moon so six
months later July twentieth anniversary
date if many of you remember for landing
on the moon and there's also these
wonderful tours and panoramas so you can
go down through google moon get into the
system and drop into a panorama that was
taken photographically at the site that
we've read it and contextually tagged
and so you actually have a wonderful way
to do your citizen science your
exploration of the moon and a much
higher fidelity that anybody anybody
except the Apollo astronauts has ever
had right and rule that around your head
for a second because it took me a minute
to actually understand that you have
access to data that nobody not even
really the Apollo astronauts had at the
time it's been composite of its been
registered it's been tagged it's been
synthesized it's been geo-located and
it's been put in an easily consumable
accessible form and you can just mean I
think you're on it now in the back right
so pay attention it's really easy to get
there it's that's what that's a
tremendous tremendous benefit that that
has come out of the partnerships we've
got so now let me tell you in my last
few minutes here about some of the stuff
that NASA Ames in particular is doing in
preparation for the next set of
exploration a particular manned
exploration that's going to be happening
sometime soon we hope but in essence
what we do is we do analog exploration
activities why the same way you practice
piano you want to practice exploring
right the same way
geologists learn by going out into the
field to see what they're looking for as
opposed to sitting in a classroom and
getting a dry lecture you want to
practice your trade NASA's trade in
doing human exploration or robotic
exploration is sending something out
into a strange environment and seeing
how well it works and seeing what it
does so we do what are called analog
missions every summer we do these things
around various locations in the country
in 2009 we did one ab and we've been
back to this place several times but a
particular place near the Grand Canyon
called the Black Point lava flow and the
reason we went is because it's got some
really nice the term is geomorphology
it's got some nice rock shapes okay and
it looks like lava flows we may see on
other planetary surfaces so we want to
go and test out our equipment see how
well it works against something that's
you know an analog right we being NASA
bought this very expensive gigapan
system and put it on this cheap robot
that was a joke yeah the actually this
is a cheap robot as far as robots go
this is a the k10 Rover at at NASA Ames
and it's part of a suite of instruments
and there's more but these are the kind
of the visual ones where we put a nice
scanning lidar system that gives you a
very high resolution topographic
measurements so you can get five
millimeter measurements at a 500 meter
distance so very fine that's where you
get your your surface shapes we
literally it's a gigapan that's exactly
what it is bought purchase well maybe
and it's sitting up there and it's
taking our panoramas and then we've got
a microscopic imager and all of these
can give us that full high gigapixel
resolution data that allows us to
explore virtually what's going on so we
take you know we start with orbital
imagery
go in take high-resolution gigapixel
panoramas and panorama zooms that allow
us to get down with the microscopic
imager to you in 55 microns per pixel
right very fine-grained zooming
capability again but this is the type of
information that then the robotic
systems provide back to the controllers
the science team to do the exploration
and there's a number of reasons you can
do this for down selecting the data the
light our system will give you an actual
you know surface understanding of what
you're seeing visually geo-located and
co referenced with the GigaPan so that
you really understand it's you know it's
not as good as being there it's not but
it's really good it really tells you a
lot about the system and if you're
trained in the particular zuv the the
science of geology but then also trained
in the use of these systems in the field
it becomes a very powerful and enabling
capability not for doing the Black Point
lava flow but for doing things like are
going to happen on the Mars Science Lab
which is the next mars rover i talked
about earlier that will be launching
later this year and getting to Mars so
we did all this data collection did
these various recons and geo tagged the
heck out of it right and so we ended up
with you know a representation of a nice
eight and a half gigabytes 52 hours of
robotic recon data 39 lidar scans 75
Giga pans 95 terrain maps right that was
our that was our week in the field right
and that is demonstrably the type of
exploration and the type of capability
that you want to enable for planetary
science that we make that we make it now
seems and this is what we're going to
have available and ready for us in the
future one of the other cool ways we do
this you know this isn't just robotic
system this is what's called the lunar
exploration rover this is our plate
lunar
over that we're dealing with and we've
mounted a GigaPan system on it it's gone
off in the field we've got it's actually
a full self-contained GigaPan system and
laptop with all the software so it does
the whole package you can just do it
right there composite them all together
and we did a whole set of citizen
science with that we're excited my next
slide yeah so d rats it was the name of
the field test where we had this gigapan
on the lunar rover and we basically they
went out we tried added a number of
things where we took just a boatload of
Giga pans put it on this site and said
you the citizen go out tell us where we
should explore what do you see what do
you find what's what's useful to you and
they helped inform so we got public
input into the final plan they helped
inform what the exploration would be
where was the interesting outcrop where
was a little widget you wanted to look
where was the cool rock what was this
stuff you could care less about and that
was basically through the GigaPan org
site you know we partnered with that and
that worked at exceptionally well we got
a huge number of hits we've got a huge
amount of interest from the public
telling us hey this is kind of
interesting you know I didn't know NASA
did this this is like you know Jamboree
for roboticists and it was but now you
allow a lot more people to join in that
exploration with you and you know the
goal is that when we go to a planetary
surface this is again the type of
capability that you have online for
everyone to get access to so it's not
just you know by reading the latest news
paper you see the latest picture right
you actually get access to the real data
to the real cool stuff so to sum up
basically one of the reasons I like
working for NASA I told some people
earlier this morning you know I'm an
engineer I'm one of those aerospace
engineers computer science is kind of a
hobby right then there's the computer
scientists and space is kind of their
hobby right the intersection works out
really well and that NASA and is is one
of the very unique organizations that we
generate some of them
most heterogeneous diverse weird data
you would ever get just comes from out
of this world it comes literally from
everywhere and so we get these multi
scale multi type multispectral data sets
we gathered from the micro sometimes
down to the to the nano scale all the
way to the macro scale and we want to
reference it and one of the key powerful
things here is that the relative or the
location context of where the images are
relative to each other and to other
systems tells you information in and of
itself it's tremendously powerful it's
how our brains are wired so it's great
stuff because of that gigapixel
exploration is here to stay it it may
have not fully started with NASA but
we've used it exceptionally well and
we're very proud of our partnership with
CMU Google and many others and the
citizens I entri science editor injury
whatever that is are you people that are
actually using these tools and
technologies to do great science out
there this is kind of the forerunner of
how it's going to be done so glad to
have spend some time here with you in
Pittsburgh Thank You ela for inviting me
the rbr transex and the percentage
covering do you guys know it's a it's a
pretty high percentage of covering so
there's a lot of overlap it basically is
doing a polar orbit and and so they're
taking these nice swathes and we're
trying to get as much overlap as you get
right now it looks kind of like an
unpeeled orange with little unfilled in
pieces but the longer it survives the
more opportunities that will be to fill
it in and flush that out so it's going
to be very very high-resolution data
it's very impressive stuff I mean you
can actually see I don't know I didn't
show any Giga pants I'm sorry but there
are some on the site and GigaPan dollar
or you can just look them up but there
are images of the Mars rover lander its
tracks and the back shell that you can
see from orbit so we're really there or
we're really faking it quite well yes
yes sir okay that's actually a really
good question and I don't have a really
solid technical answer I can give you my
my guess one it was just technically
challenging and hard to figure out how
you're going to get video because it's a
it's a it's a it's a straw in the sense
of it's a straw of a connection very
thin narrow hard to get data in and out
for long distance missions so video you
know in the idea of digitizing video
that's a relatively you know new
technology in the past 20 years that's
mature enough with all the computer
science that goes behind compressing
everything else so that was one
challenge and then I I believe me
personally that there's somewhat of a
bias in the scientific community when we
sent out the surveyors some missions
early we looked around and we thought
you know we were going to Mars and we're
going to see the canals and then we got
there and all we saw we're a bunch of
dead
readers and everyone went said oh it's a
dead planet right you remember that
phrase Mars is it dead planet and that
kind of biased people's perceptions
about what type of science they would
get we're going to a static airless
world and we just need to scratch it and
we'll be fine and you know there was
some of the biggest surprises that the
Mars rover team had was wind comes in
and brushes off the solar arrays on the
Mars rover and they the power jumps up
oh it's a little dynamic atmosphere they
took a picture once and they saw funny
world and they realized it was a dust
devil moving across the surface of Mars
and we ended up putting software on
board the Mars rover to
opportunistically capture that and you
can see a couple quick snaps of a dust
devil moving so now there's a sudden
motivation of hey maybe things are a
little bit more dynamic than we think
and so there is a desire for video but
really for technical and cultural
reasons I think we were just slow
getting there Oh Vic of a forensic
photographer we had cameras you can take
like thousand pictures of a second now
that are pretty expensive that seems to
me that you have any plans of putting
that type of image you're getting a kind
of imagery from Mars can we maybe some
of the dust ok so the MSL the Mars
Science Lab camera does add up about a
megapixel five frames per second we
think it gets up to 15 frames per second
I wasn't sure because i was looking at
old slides for a lower resolution kind
of a 800 x 600 resolution so yeah it's
we're definitely flying it and you know
the lead time between a commercially
available ccd and then making its space
rated and then sitting around and
waiting for the launch and then actually
it flying and getting there means you
know we're 10 15 years behind on a good
day technically right that's just the
way it is ok I'm available for other
questions in the hall if you'd like
you